[Music]
in a universe full of crappy Star Trek
movies but to Scott need with a starship
the best one in decades had nothing to
do with Star Trek but also everything to
do with Star Trek
whoa Galaxy Quest
Suda for a big-budget sci-fi meta comedy
about niche fandom in the 90s wow it's
like they were trying to lose money in
the satire of old school track spot-on
portrayal of fan culture and hilarious
character driven comedy that morphs into
an honest-to-goodness action flick and
ends with the film's actors playing the
show's actors playing the crew of a
starship acting out the show in reality
in front of actors playing fans of the
fake show who pretend that it's real
except that it is real and is this movie
genius or did I just smoke whatever Tony
Shalhoub is on when washed-up TV actors
get mistaken for their characters on an
old Syfy show their egos and
incompetence could doom an entire
civilization and when your movie needs a
bumbling washed-up TV actor with a
massive ego you call Tim Allen Lulla the
two man shines as a faded Captain Kirk
tide who wouldn't last 10 seconds in the
hashtag make to era misty the strange
plant is filling my head with such
thoughts but Allen's best and possibly
only example of real acting is improved
by the rest of a great cast a Sigourney
Weaver plays against her type of the
strong female lead to play two melons
supported by a wetsuit Sam Rockwell who
in the film's only flaw does not dance
at any point and the late great Alan
Rickman who walks the razor's edge of
playing an actor full of contempt for
Tim Allen and being an actor full of
contempt for Tim Allen what an insane
collection of talent did you know Dwight
sin it the crew even has the Mythbusters
for all we know that's Destiny's Child
stare in awe at a film that nailed the
rise of fan culture back when the
internet looked like this that websites
to love by the way that absolutely nails
are obsessive cataloging of pointless
details sequence is too
the fact that most hardcore fans mistake
fiction for reality he we program the
food synthesizer for each of you based
on the regional menu as your birthplace
and the insight that a fans real fantasy
isn't going on an adventure
it's finding out that all the time he's
been watching TV wasn't a colossal waste
of time it's all real you I know it's
the only thing they couldn't predict is
how much money you could make off nerds
these days if Galaxy Quest was real
they'd have a CBS all access show no one
watches and a crossover episode with the
Orville Wade is the Orville ripping off
Star Trek or Galaxy Quest so kick back
and enjoy a truly underrated film for at
least under viewed because this is a
movie with something for everyone
they got marketed like a dumb screwball
comedy
they're not just acting like heroes but
anyone who sees it loves it especially
the people in charge we've all gone on
record as saying one of our favorite
Trek films is Galaxy Quest brand see
it's JJ's favorite and everyone agrees
with his opinions right
starring to infinity and B I mean never
give up never surrender nipply no joke
here just a hardcore thank you to Alan
Rickman the marvelous mr. monk
hi I'm a nerd and that's a PC and Comic
Con Star Trek deep cut 9
[Music]
that's not what she said hey screen
junkies say it with me
never give up never surrender is now
available for digital purchase
everywhere click the box and you can
watch our first poulenc documentary all
about Galaxy Quest Thanks to everyone
for your many years of support that
allowed this to happen roses are red
these rebels are spies did you hear the
tragedy of Darth Plagueis the wise hey
remember that one summer when we died
under a table